markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident
zu den corona maßnahmen und er muss dann
auch die alleinige verantwortung für
alle taten übernehmen die jetzt in der
ukraine stattfinden meine tante
[Applaus]
ich glaube namen aller sagen zu können
auch wir unterstützt die bundesregierung
fordern einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand das ende der angriffe
das ende des schießens auf zivilisten
die anerkennung des rechtes und zwar
nicht irgendwann sondern jetzt sofort am
heutigen tag meine sehr verehrten damen
putin mag die schlacht gewinnen aber den
krieg verlieren er hat viele
fehleinschätzungen gemacht er hat die
eigene stärke offenkundig überschätzt
den widerstand des ukrainischen volkes
unterschätzt und die einheit des westens
und der nato falsch eingeschätzt ich
sagte es auch hier an der stelle bei
allen schwierigkeiten die es gibt die
einheit und geschlossenheit europas auch
der nato ist ganz wichtig und ich freue
mich über jeden amerikanischen soldaten
der auf bayerischen boden ist und
mithilft europa und die nato zu
verteidigen
[Applaus]
wir stehen alle zusammen seit an seit
mit der ukraine das leid der ukraine der
bevölkerung ist groß wir haben ein
großes mitgefühl und empathie
wir sind alle ukraine in diesen zeiten
ich danke ausdrücklich für die viele
solidarität und die hilfe in münchen
kamen 45.000 menschen zusammen übrigens
mehr als sie eine corona demo in bayern
hatte mein dank übrigens auch ihr die
bayerische spd ihren cia von brunn es
war eine gute eine wichtige aktion
herzliches dankeschön an alle die dabei
waren mann ist er führt momentan
es ist beeindruckend wie viele helfen
kinder und schüler backen kuchen um
spenden zu erlösen für die ukraine
unzählige einzelpersonen fahren auf
eigene gefahr und eigene verantwortung
eigene kosten transporte von hilfsgütern
an die gratis in die grenzbereiche
unternehmen vereine sportler künstler
alle gemeinden helfen helfen mit mein
besonderer dank auch ganz wieder an die
wohlfahrtsorganisationen
stellvertretend frau präsidentin des
bayerischen roten kreuzes die
wohlfahrtsorganisationen stehen erneut
in dieser krise wieder an vorderster
front seit zwei jahren im dauer krisen
modus und sie leisten großartige arbeit
herzliches dankeschön an alle
helferinnen ist
als ministerpräsident bin ich stolz und
dankbar dass bayern hilft wie bayern
hilft bayern zeigt ein großes herz die
gefühle und zur bevölkerung sind aber
zwei geteilt und zum teil auch das
gespalten auf der einen seite großes
mitgefühl und empathie auf der anderen
seite auch die wachsende sorge was
bedeutet das alles auf dauer für unsere
sicherheit sind ja auch für unseren
wohlstand
ich darf das sichern und versprechen wir
nehmen alle sorgen ernst wir haben alles
im blick wir wollen helfen ich sage an
der stelle war auch ganz eindeutig weil
es heute morgen unsichere bemerkung gab
wir verstehen den wunsch der ukraine
nach noch mehr einsatz auch dort aber
fürs militärische sei klar gesagt wir
sind nicht konfliktpartei dies ist kein
nato fall und es soll auch keinen
einsatz dort an der stelle geben wir
helfen sehr gerne aber das ist nicht
notwendig und nicht geeignet und nicht
richtig deutschland soll nicht eine
konfliktpartei unmittelbar an den
kämpfen werden man ist sehr fällt noch
mutter
wir müssen also entschlossen und
besonnen handeln mit herz und kühlem
kopf unsere strategie basiert auf drei
säulen hilfe sanktionen und schutz
unseres landes
hilfe heißt vor allen dingen eben
hilfstransporten schutz für die menschen
die zu uns kommen die geflohen sind es
sind sehr viele auf der flucht es werden
täglich mehr je länger der krieg dauert
bayern ist auch hier bereit mit großem
herzen zu helfen überall arbeiten alle
rund um die uhr die menschen das habe
ich selbst leben dürfen sind übrigens
sehr sehr dankbar sie sind dankbar dass
eine unterbringung aufnahme erfolgt und
viele sind auch wirklich froh dass die
gerüchte gestreut wird nicht stimmen wie
man hier behandelt wird man sieht
übrigens wie in jedem krieg auf der
einen seite ist der kugelhagel in der
ukraine aber auf der anderen seite die
massiven fällt muss die gesteuert und
geströmt werden um die menschen zu
verunsichern
natürlich klappt nicht alles perfekt und
alles sofort sind übrigens alle nur
menschen ich danke allen auch den
kommunen auch der landeshauptstadt dafür
dass sich alles so einsätzen in dieser
schweren zeit wir wollen uns auch weiter
eng abstimmen und verzahnen dass sie
wird es morgen eine konferenz geben mit
allen oberbürgermeistern und landräten
in bayern und das weitere vorgehen zu
beraten
ein bisschen schade fand ich was ich
letzte woche hier im landtag gehört habe
da gab es sehr sehr schrill vorwürfe
wenn ich das so sagen darf bayern tue
nichts wenn dann falsches bayern sei
unsichtbar und die vorfälle ging auch
sehr stark an den innenministern im
bayrischen ich möchte ihm hier an der
stelle meinen persönlichen dank
aussprechen ich finde es deplatziert in
krisenzeiten wer sich in krisenzeiten so
benimmt und so schnell agiert der zeigt
dass er krisen nicht gewachsenes mannes
wie hält man organisieren und zwar mit
hochdruck der k fall war übrigens schon
die ganze zeit da wurde nie aufgehoben
wir nehmen auf wir versorgen wir
organisieren die unterbringung ja wie
registrieren selbst alles durch die
polizei bisher sind 50.000 menschen nach
bayern gekommen weil ein in münchen fast
täglich rund 1500 auch hier in münchen
alle im einsatz 24 stunden aufnahme
service zum beispiel der caritas die
unterbringung wird organisiert in ast
anlaufstellen anker zentren
gemeinschaftsunterkünften wie wohnheimen
pensionen gasthöfe zusätzlich bereiten
die allen messen turnhallen und es gibt
gespräch auch mit kirchen und klöstern
um alle potenziale an alle möglichkeiten
zu nutzen
dabei geht es übrigens nicht nur um die
unterbringung es ist der erste schritt
wir müssen auch weiterhelfen speziell
für kinder und jugendliche die in diesem
krieg besonders betroffen sind und die
ganz besonders in großer zahl zu uns
kommen dort gibt es die psychosoziale
betreuung die rasche integration in
schule und kita ich begrüße ausdrücklich
die aktivitäten des kultusministeriums
pädagogische willkommens klassen zu
machen noch vor der schulpflicht in der
zeit der drei monate auch die
personalgewinnung ist hier nicht einfach
da wird alles getan und versucht unter
anderem auch mögliche geflüchteten
lehrkräfte aus der ukraine zu nehmen
unser eigentliches problem meine sehr
verehrten und haben wir bislang
jedenfalls dass man nie genau wusste
wann und wie viele menschen kommen warum
weil die informationen die national
gegeben wurden sehr knapp war der
innenminister hat mir berichtet dass es
manchmal erst eine stunde vor lauf gibt
um zu sagen ob und wann ein zug
beispielsweise in münchen 18 das soll
jetzt besser werden zum glück
der bund hatte sich lange gewehrt noch
am wochenende hieß es eigentlich braucht
es keine verteilung es gab da übrigens
relativ großen ärgern den bundesländern
bundesländer wie berlin brandenburg oder
hamburger so keine unions länder haben
angemahnt dies müsse besser koordiniert
werden der bund wird jetzt nachbessern
dies ist gut denn wir brauchen auch hier
klare leitlinien und zwar nicht nur für
ein zwei tage sondern für die nächsten
wochen jeder der glaubt dass dieser
konflikt im zwei drei wochen vorbei ist
der ist naiv
wir brauchen eine bundes koordinierung
mit den ländern ähnlich wie bei krone
wir brauchen eine registrierung aller
schutz suchen in deutschland wir
brauchen eine gerechte verteilung auf
alle länder nach dem königsteiner
schlüssel auch in der eu wobei ich an
der stelle anmerken möchte das was polen
ungarn derzeit leistet ist enorm und
verdient unsere große anerkennung meines
er versammelt haben
und wir brauchen den vollständigen
kostenersatz für die ländern die
kommunen bayern ist hier wieder in
vorleistung gegangen für den hinweis
bayern würde allein lassen und sei nicht
sichtbar wir haben von anfang an gesagt
wir übernehmen alle kosten
vorläufig aber die abrechnung muss am
ende vernünftig erfolgen durch den bund
meine damen und herren wir alle haben
unseren beitrag zu leisten die kommunen
helfen vor ort der freistaat bayern
unterstützt und steuert jetzt ist es
wichtig dass der bund auch endlich
seiner verantwortung nachkommt dies kann
nur gemeinsam gehen der bund auf länder
und kommunen nicht allein lassen man ist
[Applaus]
wir helfen
zweite säule sanktionen natürlich sind
sanktionen das zentrale druckmittel auf
moskau wir stehen zu 100 prozent dazu
aber klar es gibt auch deutliche
bremsspuren bei uns und sie werden jeden
tag sichtbar die folgen für die
wirtschaft sind natürlich immens
lieferketten brechen über nacht zusammen
dies führt zu produktionsstopp
kurzarbeit bei bmw audi bei stahlwerken
bei automobilzulieferern und natürlich
auch beim maschinenbau dazu kommt der
ausfall der speditionen weil viele
lkw-fahrer nicht da sein können daher
braucht es auch für die wirtschaft bei
stand es geht um sehr sehr viele
arbeitsplätze in unserem land deswegen
ist wichtig die kurzarbeit auszuweiten
kreditprogramme von kfw und lfa zu
erweitern und ja es braucht notwendig
auch noch mal eine anpassung der
bisherigen corona überbrückungshilfe
dafür die unternehmen planen doch alle
bereits um unternehmen wollen sich
unabhängig machen von den lieferketten
aber zur unterdrückung ist hilfe nötig
ich finde meine damen und herren wir
sind jetzt zwei jahre durch die schwere
krone zeit gekommen und haben uns
wirtschaftlich gut dargestellt wir
sollten jetzt an der stelle auch bei der
beistand unterstützung für wirtschaft
und arbeitsplätze leisten
die sanktionen würden finanzsektor und
anderswo aber natürlich am wirksamsten
als druckmittel sind sicherlich die
sanktionen im energie sektor dies trifft
russland hart aber für uns ist es nicht
einfach wir erleben explodierte
energiepreise und eine hyperinflation
die übrigens schon bereits vor dem
ukraine krieg sich sehr stark entwickelt
hat beim sprit ist der größte sprung
aller zeiten den wir derzeit dies
belastet millionen deutsche und bayern
nicht darauf angewiesen sind und
natürlich die wirtschaft ja es geht um
die ukraine aber es geht auch um die
soziale lage der menschen bei uns
zum thema auch was die letzten tage
diskutiert wurde wie ist es denn
eigentlich wer ist für was
verantwortlich dass deutschland
überhaupt in der gas herausforderung ist
mit russland möchte ich nur eines sagen
hab da vieles gehört und gelesen eines
muss man aber sagen die abhängigkeit von
gas ist keine erscheinung der letzten
jahre und der letzten zehn jahre es
wurde in den siebziger jahren
entschieden beginnen von willy brandt
das
deutschland mit russland eine gas
partnerschaft eingeht deutschland baut
die pipeline russland liefert das gas
dies hat helmut schmid fortgesetzt
gerhard schröder natürlich auch angela
merkel und die wahrheit ist eindeutig
vor allem nach dem ausstieg aus der
atomenergie hat jeder in deutschland
jeder war der festen überzeugung dass
wir dann eine brückentechnologien gas
brauchen deswegen möchte ich nur
anmerken für alle die jetzt sagen der
oder der ist schuld dass einzel
verhalten von personen kann man sagen
aber dies war nationale entscheidungen
und herr vorwurf zusage an die
bayerische staatsregierung hätte eine
abhängigkeit produziert wurde gesamte
energiepolitik in bonn oder berlin
gemacht wurde ist im besten falle falsch
im schlechtesten fall politisch
fragwürdig mannes
[Applaus]
also was ist zu tun sanktionen klar mehr
jahr stark habe ja auf jeden fall aber
wir sollten bei jedem einzelnen schritt
auch noch mal die folgen bedenken recht
zu finden der ausstieg aus öl und kohle
aus russland ist schnell organisierbar
diese alex bahr wie sieht es beim sofort
stoppt bei gas aus ein sofortiges
gas-embargo
ich gebe zu wie viele andere menschen
habe ich emotionale sympathie dafür weil
uns ärgert und beschwert dass wir jeden
tag quasi geld nach russland überweisen
müssen
aber ich gebe auch zu es gibt eine
andere seite sie sagt auch die
bundesregierung ich habe das selber lebt
ich habe mit der bayerischen wirtschaft
mit der gesamten bayerischen wirtschaft
nicht schuldig gemacht mit den
automobilisten maschinenbauer ihk svww
dort gab es an den deutlichen waren und
hilferuf die folgen zb für unsere
energieintensive wirtschaft sind bei
einem sofortigen unmittelbaren hals über
kopf ausstieg zumindest unabsehbar das
könnte das ende des deutschen business
modells und in sozialen abstieg für
viele millionen deutsche bedeutung als
minister sind kümmere ich mich natürlich
und die menschen in der ukraine
aber ich bin auch mitverantwortlich für
die soziale lage und der arbeitsplätze
für unsere bayern
so gut es klingt und gut gemeint ist ich
würde es wirklich sagen so gut ist
klingt frieren für den frieden autofreie
sonntage fasten für die ukraine sind am
endeffekt kein belastbares konzept für
eine wirtschafts nation wie deutschland
und bayern meine damen und herren das
ziel ist klar wir wollen komplett
unabhängig werden von russland in der
energiefrage
und der bund selbst wird dazu und soll
auch dazu einen energieplan vorlegen wir
müssen wissen in welchen zeitachsen
realistisch es einen energiepolitischen
independence day von russland geben kann
und nach dieser zeit achse müssen wir
dann die maßnahmen für die
energiepolitik treffen die anfangs
maßnahmen sind ja klar jetzt mal die
gasspeicher zu fühlen
flüssiggasterminals zu bauen sehr gut
aber es sind wir bei der realistisch die
schnellsten zeitachsen für neue
flüssiggasterminals im norden dürften
bis 2025 26 dies ist eine längere zeit
und auf diese zeit müssen wir planen und
deswegen nicht weil wir das wollen oder
besondere anhänger sind sondern weil wir
das vernünftig erwägung überlegen macht
es doch keinen sinn abzuschalten was
noch läuft wir haben jetzt
energieprobleme die preise explodieren
und wenn uns energie fehlt dann noch
eigene energie vom netz zu nehmen meine
damen und herren ist unverständlich 70
prozent der deutschen sagen nicht
abschalten nicht abschalten gilt für
kohle aber es tut mir leid auch wenn es
ideologisch dem ein landwirt dies gilt
nun auch für die kernkraft maniche sehr
werden
das bayerische umweltministerium als
genehmigungsbehörde überprüfungs bürde
sagt eine laufzeit verlängerung ist
möglich
sa2 also nicht abständen stellen
vielleicht gundremmingen wieder ans netz
nehmen vorläufig für maximal drei jahre
allein wenn man die drei restlichen noch
in deutschland laufenden kernkraftwerke
am netz lässt gibt dass strom für zehn
millionen haushalte in deutschland
dafür bräuchte man als ersatz mindestens
3000 windräder und selbst die größten
optimisten glauben nicht dass das über
den winter erfolgen kann daher brauchen
wir eine brücke und die brücke heißt im
moment die laufen lassen der kernkraft
ich sage ihnen eins verlängern ist
vernünftig abschalten ideologisch und
ehrlicherweise die ganze europäische
union setzt in diesen zeiten darauf als
ergänzung manche sogar hauptsächlich
kernkraft weiter zu betreiben warum
glauben wir dass wir schlauer sind als
unsere gesamten europäischen freunde
meine sehr verehrten
[Applaus]
das allein reicht aber natürlich nicht
schon klar natürlich müssen ja auch bei
erneuerbaren energien voran kommen
ich bin manchmal überrascht wenn über
bayern da geredet wird und an der stelle
auch gerade hier im landtag wie wenig
der landtag da waren etwas bayern
eigentlich ist bayern ist das spitzen
land der erneuerbaren energien es ist so
ich hab selber als umweltminister an der
stelle damals mitgearbeitet übrigens mit
dem kollegen zeil damals von der fdp und
haben die energiekonzepte entwickelt die
bis heute tragen bayern ist in
deutschland in fast allen erneuerbaren
energie nummer eins photovoltaik wasser
biomasse geothermie nur in einer der
regenerativen energien sind wir nicht
nummer eins das stimmt natürlich sind
wir beim wind sind wir beim wind letzter
in deutschland sind wir der schlechteste
falsch wir liegen meine damen und herren
auf platz acht mit anzahl installierter
leistung unsere freunde aus baden
württemberg liegen auf platz zwölf
hinter uns liegen länder hessen sachsen
thüringen all diese länder haben zum
beispiel eine grüne
regierungsbeteiligung ich mach keinen
vorwurf aber eins würde ich sagen immer
hier im landtag etwas zu fordern was man
selbst in der eigenen
regierungsverantwortung nicht umsetzen
kann da würde ich immer sagen erst die
hausaufgaben machen bevor man andere
kritisiert und belehrt
[Applaus]
schauen wir noch ein bisschen genauer
hin ich finde gerade bei mindestens
spannen der vergleich mit unseren
nachbarn baden württemberg es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen bayern und baden
württemberg und bayern sind schwarzer in
baden württemberg grüne minister wir
sind ein den ich sehr schätze die
ergebnisse beim wind sind aber gar nicht
so unterschiedlich gab es gerade
angesprochen baden württemberg hat den
letzten zehn jahren werden sie zu das
ist einfach für die faktenlage gut zu
wissen dann braucht man fakten hat
braucht man nicht ideologisch
argumentieren ganz einfach also nur in
zehn windräder in zwei jahren die
leistung liegt hinter bayern als
sozusagen 10h sei an allem schuld ist
ehrlicherweise nicht zutreffend ich
glaube dies ist keine politische
problematik sondern eine topografische
und geografische denn die realität ist
der süden ist keine optimale wind region
im norden ist wind stark und sonne
schwach im süden ist sony stark und wind
schwach ich bin endlich einmal die
natürlichen realitäten mit einzubeziehen
und zu akzeptieren
winfried kretschmann zu hören winfried
kretschmann moniert sehr stark
das eine ist der grundprobleme sei dass
die ausschreibungs quoten für wind die
nationalen den süden massiv
benachteilige ihr habt recht
besetzungs gemeinsam ein dass die
südgruppe endlich durchgesetzt wird bei
der eu hier kann uns der bund sehr sehr
helfen
übrigens ich bin sportler willkommen
zurück ins studio meine damen und herren
das war so markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident und hier bekomme ich
gerade einen anruf kann jetzt nicht
rangehen
vielleicht
gar nicht mal gesehen das war meine frau
ehrlich gesagt aber so weil wir über
markus söder die regierungserklärung
gerade zum einen die ukraine zum anderen
die energie sprechen wir zuerst über die
ukraine er hat sich im wesentlichen das
angeschlossen was
auch die bundesregierung sei in der tat
und was markus söder jetzt da doch
stärker versucht weil er ja
innenpolitisch muss man sagen auch in
der eigenen partei ziemlich unter druck
ist angesichts schlechter
umfrage-ergebnisse er hat so ein
bisschen versuch gerade im ersten teil
der rede der präsident von bayern zu
sein der also mit vielen dank selbst die
opposition beispielsweise die spd
bedacht hat für ihre unterstützung auch
bei demonstrationen gegen den krieg
gegen putins überfall auf die ukraine
hatten demonstranten als gegen die krone
regeln hat er noch ganz genau hat auch
natürlich den helfern vom roten kreuz
gedankt also das war im ersten teil der
rede die wir gesehen haben der markus
söder der also über ein bayern steht und
versucht da statur zu gewinnen dem man
jeden seinen dank ausspricht dann
interessanter punkt morgen wird ja
darüber beraten im bundeskabinett
welches paket kann man schnüren um die
menschen zu entlasten es geht also um
das thema energie die abhängigkeit von
russland reduzieren und er der sich
lange einen grünen anstrich gegeben
hatte noch vor dem wahlkampf also ein
bisschen das ruder herumgerissen hatte
hat also jetzt ganz klar dafür plädiert
kohle und kernkraft nicht abzuschalten
ja markus söder ist bekannt dafür dass
er ja gerne mal eine 180 grad wendung
hinlegt haben wir im wahlkampf im
vergangenen jahr immer wieder gesehen
aber auch davor
als der ministerpräsident
war oder gerade geworden war und eine
wahl hingelegt hat im herbst 20 18 nicht
so richtig gut ausging für die csu
danach hat er der csu einen massiv
grünen anstrich gegeben hat sie auf öko
kurs getrimmt und jetzt wieder eine
kehrtwende markus dass ich der erste
prominente unionspolitiker
das muss man sagen der sich ganz klar
für einen weiterbetrieb der
kernkraftwerke der drei verbliebenen
deutschland aus spricht wird ende des
jahres abgeschwächt genauso ist ende 20
22 gegen die letzten drei vom netz und
markus söder sagt und dabei ist er noch
deutlicher einig als friedrich merz er
sagt das kann nicht sein dass wir bei
der ganzen problematik die wir jetzt
sehen erdgas aus russland öl aus
russland sollen wir alles am besten
nicht mehr importieren und dann noch
drei meiler abschalten die ohnehin noch
laufen also da ist er der prominenteste
der erste mit wieder einer kehrtwende
markus söder plötzlich wieder auf
atomkurs bittere ironie dabei auch das
uran dass wir brauchen kommt aus
kasachstan und zu großen teilen aus
russland ist richtig ganz genau das ist
ein problem die grünen versuchen
natürlich massiv diese
laufzeitverlängerung zu verhindern es
gibt verschiedene vermerke aus dem
ministerium von robert habeck dem
wirtschaftsminister woraus hervorgeht
dass ein weiterbetrieb nicht möglich ist
aus verschiedenen gründen aber er hat
markus söder sicherlich auch argumente
auf seiner seite